على حاكموا مقاطعه دونيسكا الموالي لروسيا
دينيس بوشيليني ان جميع طرق المؤديه الى
مدينه باغموت بات تحت السيطره الناريه
للقوات الروسيه من جانبه على قائد عسكري
في ميليشيات فاجنر ان قواته سيطرت بالكامل
على حيز تبكي دون خسائر ومن جهته قلائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيين الوضع في محيط
متوتر للغايه في ظل تطبيق ميليشيات
وابدا معك حسان وما الذي تقوله السلطات
الاوكرانيه بخصوص تطورات الوضع في
السلطات الاوكرانيه منذ وقت طويل تؤكد على
ان الاوضاع في بخموت هي اوضاع صعبه على
لسان الرئيس الاوكراني وحتى على لسان
المسؤولين
العسكريين الاوكرانيين وتزداد صعوبه على
الارض في ظل القصف المتواصل لهذه المنطقه
والتصريحات الاخيره كانت واضحه بهذا
الخصوص على لسان قائد القوات البريه
الاوكراني الذي اكد على ان الوضع في بخموت
متوتر للغايه وصعب للغايه في اخر تصريحاته
وهو ايضا ما جاء على لسان هيئه الاركان
عليا الاوكرانيه التي اكدت كذلك على ان
القوات
الاوكرانيه تتصدى للهجمات على عدد من
المحاور وابرز هذه المحاور محور باخمت
وتحدثت خلاله عن
هجمه خلال هذا اليوم هذا ياتي ايضا
في ظل حديث اوكراني على انها على ان
اوكرانيا تستعد
لهجوم مضاد على مختلف الجبهات خلال الاشهر
القادمه ابرز هذه التصريحات ايضا جاءت على
لسان رئيس المخابرات
الاوكراني
كريليو بودانوف الذي قال ان اوكرانيا
تستعد خلال الاشهر المقبله
لتغيرا في الواقع وان الاشهر المقبله
ستحدد مسار الاحداث في اوكرانيا ليس على
محور دنياتك فحسب انما على كافه الجبهات
هذا ايضا
وفي مقابله صحفيه اشار ايضا الى حديث
عن مساله المقترح
الصيني
للسلام وقال ان
الصين في حديثه عن موضوع الاسلحه تحديدا
قال انه لا يرى اي مؤشرات على ان الصين
تقدم اسلحه لروسيا امين في دنيا ماذا عن
اخر تطورات حسب القوات المواليه لروسيا
تتمثل في تاكيد رئيس دنيتك الموالي لروسيا
هنا
على ان كل طرق المؤديه الى مدينه تحت
السيطره الناريه للقوات الروسيه واكد على
ان تفجير القوات الاوكرانيه قبل ثلاثه
ايام لسد على قناه مائيه في شمال مدينه
باخمه لم يحل دون تقدم ومواصله اقتحام
قوات فاجنر للاحياء الشماليه من المدينه
وهدم اكدته اليوم وكاله فان الروسيه التي
كانت قد بثت صورا من حيث تبكي الذي اعلن
عن سيطره قوات فاجنر عليه امس وهذا يعني
طبعا بان قوات فاجنر باتت بالفعل داخل
مدينه
ضخموت على الرغم من ان الحديث عن دخولها
الى قلب مدينه بخموت مازال غير مؤكد حتى
الان هي تتواجد اذا نظرنا الى الخريطه في
الجهه الشرقيه جهه جنوبيه وايضا في جهه
الشماليه
الغربيه وتتحرك نحو اتجاهات متعدده خاصه
باتجاه بلده خروموفا على ما يبدو في
محاوله لقطعه طريق الامداد بين بخموت
ومدينه سوفيار بعد ان كانت الطريق الرابطه
بين بخموت وكانستانتين
بحسب قوات فاجنر هذا التقدم وهذه المعارك
المتواصله تقابلها ايضا معارك لا تقل
اهميه وحده بين الجانبين ساحتها مدينه
افديفكا الملاصقه لمدينه دنيتك امس كان
يوما
يعني غير هادئ بالمره باصوات القصف كانت
تصلنا الى مدينه دنياسك بعد بعض القذائف
سقطت على بعض الاحياء في شمال وغرب مدينه
دنيات كما ادى الى جرح مدني واحد على
الاقل وهذا ان دل على شيء فانما يدل على
احتدام
التي تعجبها مهمه جدا بالنسبه للموالين
لروسيا هنا في مقاطعه
باعتبار انهم لطالما التهم وجانب
الاوكراني بقصف بعض المناطق الخاضعه
للسيطرتهم انطلاقا من
ايضا في الجنوب في مارينكا رئيس الموالي
لروسيا اعترف
بصعوبه المعارك في هذه البلده وارجع ذلك
الى قيام القوات الاوكرانيه بتحصين هذه
البلده الصغيره المتاخمه لدنيات من جهه
الجنوب على مدى تسع سنوات اي منذ اندلاع
الصراع في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا عام 2014
وايضا في جنوب مدينه دانياسكو تحديدا في
وبليدار هناك ما زالت معارك محتدمه بين
الجانبين دون تحقيق القوات الروسيه لاي
تقدم ملموس على الارض على الاقل منذ
اسابيع
والشكر كذلك موصول لحسان مسعود